look the thing that has to happen now is
this guy just needs to be inundated with
shots of his sister everywhere it
becomes the whole thing gets a male
it goes he opens his window
[Music]
so this this story you're gonna love oh
I think uh there's a a guy named Aiden
Ross huge on Twitch huge on YouTube
um he's streaming right he's got a
sister that does uh that's hot yeah his
sister does only fans
um he's in the middle of his stream
where he's kind of just like looking at
um User submitted photos and videos and
whatever oh no he pulls up this video of
like a tree branch being cut and before
it follows the edit switches and it just
shows him a picture of his own sister
naked with jizz on her back oh my God
that's a great move but here's the
actual video that happened it's pretty
funny why
ah
he pauses it is just too far bro he
paused it
way too [__] far bro
y'all literally just went too [__]
far with that without him bro
that's not even funny bro y'all just
literally have to blow it up show me my
naked sister
I'm not on her back bro that [__] is too
far
he looks like he's about to laugh you
gotta be I mean that's pretty funny
that's [__] funny bro that's
hilarious but wait he didn't get in
trouble for showing that it's on Kick I
don't know if they have different rules
or something it's not on Twitch damn
that is too far but it's [__] funny
if you're not him but it's also your
isn't he like the biggest he's one of
the biggest yeah biggest dude yeah isn't
that funny if even if it is him like if
you are him is his sister like facing
the camera too she said on her back
she's about going like this hello
holy sh maybe this angle yeah I mean I
don't got a sister so I don't know but I
just think it's still I mean coming from
guys with hot sisters like isn't that a
positive thing though like you're like
whoa [__] yeah dude this guy does not
have sisters they have hot sisters you
know I actually have an ugly sister that
I'd never talk about so really yeah
because
she's ugly dude like keep that [__]
Quasimodo in the goddamn attic you know
what the heck you got to be able to brag
about your sister I never talked about
her once because she's a [__] we
always kept her handcuffed to the closet
and
it's not a family heirloom you know yeah
this is a family heirloom though I'm
showing him the photo I'll tell you that
right now
gather around children gather around oh
you could tell that's a sister wow
I don't think that this is too far
imagine if that popped up and that was
your sister oh this is a hot sister she
looks like a hot pack of Farmer John
sausages how come he's not proud of his
hot sister she has the feel like she
looks like a big pack of Farmer John's
damn that's a dangerous World dude
that's a dangerous world look dude when
your sister is on only fans and you are
a public figure you better believe
people are gonna do that yeah look at
Ben Shapiro dude his sister has some big
Heavies yeah
yeah send that shoot to him all day long
dude the hardest part is that Ben
there's a girl that looks exactly like
Ben Shapiro's sister but she does only
fans and people always think it's the
same person and it's so weird yeah and
those bench superhero goals hey guys
that's just way too far that's too much
you know okay I could take a good joke
okay like I have a great the left likes
to manipulate
a great sense of humor but this is just
not funny it's just it's just horrendous
it's not good what exactly exactly that
is that is true you would say that so
like on this uh on this side do they is
it like twitch where they get money like
donated from fans yes Anthony it is okay
so at what point how much would it be
where it's like because like he had this
event and all his fans like were
sympathizing or whatever and like
started giving money at what point at
what amount of value are you like ah
[__] it that was worth it dude this
guy's rolling in cash this kid yeah and
his sister probably do you think how
much of her sister his sister's
marketing though is because oh you know
his sister's doing only fans what like
who came who came first dude the guy on
her back who's the marketing
look the thing that has to happen now is
this guy just needs to be inundated with
shots of his sister everywhere he
[__] goes now it becomes the whole
thing gets a male
he goes he opens his window
so if you're Internet troll right and
you see this video and he gets that big
of a reaction fly honey that's it right
let's go we got we got the Trap yeah we
know what to do this like this that's
exactly what you want oh baby let's
[__] go remember that guy that kept
going on news somehow and he goes
[__] by the [__] yeah yes yeah but
it was never real I think those are all
like simulated oh but then people yeah
the first one was fake but people
copying it were doing it on real news
things oh dude I'm sending them I'm
sending him wrapped gifts for unboxing
episodes this guy opens up a [__] box
and opens up it's a frame picture of his
sister's ass getting [__] all over
yeah dude if you had your YouTube
channel what else would you do well I
did something similar to this with guys
like real real brothers right so we got
the sister like you want to play prank
on your brother it's like yeah so we got
him to wear yoga pants like tight
[__] yoga pants and we're taking
pictures I'm like having them bend over
and [__] pick up quarters for me and
[__] and I'm like I'm like photographing
them can't see their face yet and then I
get one with their face so then I set up
a production thing like a fake
production for like when we're doing
like a casting call for new reality show
whatever the [__] maybe MTV or something
so we want big characters and big voices
and big attitudes come on in guys so
she's like hey we want guys to be guys
like guys being guys like.com like we
don't know what like TV time yeah
exactly we don't know what the show's
gonna be called yet but it's about guys
being guys and talking about chicks and
then these guys are like so they're all
like you know knowing that they really
Juice It Up right and I'm like all right
let me show you pictures of chicks I
want you to rate them and just give us
your thoughts and so I'm like I pull up
a picture of the the girl's ass and he's
like oh baby those are some cakes let me
I would I [__] wanna okay and all
that kind of [__] and then like I'm like
I'm like just so you know and I flipped
it over I'm like that's your sister and
then they're just like like
they're like [__] horrified dude and
these
and I had the chicks on site to come in
and [__] oh yeah I remember that's
the best dude so then the sisters are
coming like right what'd you think of
the pictures of these guys like I can't
[__] believe this [__] this one guy
it was about to be like he got too horny
he's like thanksgiving's gonna be so
[__] crazy this year because that
video is coming out
what's the name of that video uh Steve
Green's sister prank oh my God that's so
funny I've never seen that one got hits
on his sister prank yeah so he
weaponized that wow
look at this guy dude pictures of girls
and then reveals their sister
I'm here with
and uh
I'm good man let's get started so so
here's the first girl here uh there's a
nice booty shot that's all right
not his sister
about uh
six six
this is the full shot
oh it's not his sister first yeah
thank you
all right this is from I probably give
her
but it's a little over six little over
six and the Last Dance Just to be clear
was what okay let's see
okay
yeah oh yeah that's that's real good
Steve just [__] pouring gasoline
oh no
oh you can shake that
I might do this thing
some people think I'll probably do it
with the moves but he's talking about it
four fingers yeah
you come this way so you get two fingers
so you get what is it so you cuff it
yeah
you were so good at holding it together
Steve's so excited
yeah
this host is so relatable
you can just that yeah
run a shot here
a little shot
oh my God
yeah
I promise
oh my God
you smack that it's nice like it's like
it's not like nuggets
now I'm getting to the point where I'm
like oh no
wow
now I give it a zero
[Music]
so you know that's your sister dude
oh yeah
I probably shouldn't say it right
I learned something today oh my god did
the girls ever come out and be like ah
six
[Music]